alright guys we've weighed this long
here it is the heist finale is the last
one in the game glass heist 5 the heist
right not no more setup missions no
nothing that's right okay alright
this heist has the highest reward that's
a mill lock that up to 20 I think okay
give me give me those shares Rob thank
you to it wait you saw this are you dare
you greedy oh I just bought a condo for
half a million
alright alright yeah that looks more
like a 40 20 20 20 yeah he's fine hope
you guys are happy with this I can do
that so we got to go to the Pacific
Standard Bank yep then we got to get to
get away bikes and we have to head out
to the caddy that's quite a drive for
the bikes isn't it I assume it'll be a
really casual ride problem yeah I'll see
you there clowns
I like these alright let's go right you
look like you just murdered your Butler
alright once you drive my stupid car
Aundre
I'll get anyone want the penguin be on
alright folks this is what we've all
been waiting for is it Carlos Slim huh
okay slow and steady it also crashed
Saturday is anyone else getting all
nervous yeah well yeah I've got like a
I'm in day you got I'm sweaty I'm so
nervous I just blew past the bank imma
do kiss mode I'm going full focus baby
all right what's your stoked level 11
this is it guys trying to take a picture
of me already
that's something oh my god and the bank
together bit here we go
grip what's the note we couldn't look
more Michael robbing this Bank pick that
up
hey your crack bag
great here we go here we go here we go
here we go getting ours all guards dad
yeah I like to shoot it yeah work
there's a tellers gate that opens up I'm
putting a put the explosives on the gate
here oh that's awesome
why should I shot that guy don't shoot
anyone else Mary look away from the gate
it's gonna burn your eyes Danny you look
very calm Thanks it's not my first rodeo
you know yeah Charlie okay we're in
we're losing the crowd I don't know the
time this shoot near there but nobody
likes to get there but I'll be shooting
at people for no reason
oh shoot don't shoot them second gates
open let's move people
you get this crap and then there's a
couple of security guards down here oh
hey tight well trim a school hack the
planet baby let's do this what minigame
do like I could play today I got I got
some red lines on my map oh look at this
I'm getting shot great this guy's trying
to crawl I'm getting shot I was both
just going for us I'm not familiar how
to do this new okay what am I doing here
I assume I'm picking the red letters so
see our am I'm gonna kill day and John's
a cream boy oh no you guys are good you
guys are my upstairs yeah we had a since
our fire but we're okay that's great
eating my chuckling this kid oh whoa he
pulled out a gun I think you guys yeah I
think you guys are all another one
period a formal charge oh all right oh
you know I didn't even realize we have a
time ago
cops are closing with the gate that's
the gay [ __ ] one more of these things
okay we got the cash here we go here we
go it's just you and I grab cash think
so yeah I don't know nothing egg oh this
[ __ ] there's no this is great
hold on there's a security guard coming
up Marisol I think we got to make the
call about how much cash we take okay
hold off these people as much as you can
Roger that you take do your thing we got
this just go for it all dude with covert
ops get it all the take is currently it
- oh my god this is great
get the whole meadow get the whole meal
oh yeah the whole shebang
we're 3/4 here we go keep shaking baby
I'm loving it oh here we go
I got my accent I got it all good all
right we're at 3 minutes 20 let's go we
got the mill let's get out of here go
here we go as soon as we walk out those
doors can be [ __ ] chaos pandemonium
go go go go go go go go go go Dog Day
Afternoon outside yeah regroup hold on
let me deposit okay all right
I'm bring on my assault rifles kidding
okay
all right folks stay frosty there ya go
frost is the name of this game it's a
deposit in the ATM oh yeah where we
leave yeah where they need some of my
explosives for this oh hey there a back
door [ __ ] doesn't look like it all right
[ __ ] ducks fly together let's do it
oh my god when we get ended up hey how
about that armored truck
they're mine it's gone her okay so the
take is getting damaged it's like
pottery out of our bags or something
[ __ ] Loen car you just had a run we got
our line the route get these cops get
these cops
all right we're supposed to just run
yeah get these cops nice work work
together work together you watch the
alleyway there might be people down
there screams scoot shoot and scoot go
go go do we lost so much money already I
think I lost like a hundred out oh my
god don't worry we gotta keep careful
Kevlar coming from behind us as well I'm
dead I get a cut I'm getting him all
right I'm using a grenade watch any when
you die did you lose a lot more
oh - [ __ ] why don't just spawned in
front of me what the [ __ ] yeah having
the other spawning straight up and firm
just like real cops okay I'm dead again
I don't call that the end of it ya know
so ah all right well we want to go we
have to kill the people to the right
because they shoot us from behind all
right I'll be focused on left Mary you
clear up on the right then well behind
us behind us behind us
yep it's children coming on the corner
you got [ __ ] to do is you go for that
like I'll go no no no we could just do
that for fun beautiful shoppers down
well that's her name is Auburn oh great
flaming car
we're gonna use this and cuz hi got we
got him up Oh what
well what's going on this is guy right
here Cowboys I just do their talk man
you were looking at the other guy he's
around the corner what was a inferences
I die too
what how I got so far the first time was
I went in here and started jumping over
my clothes to the alley yeah
armor up Oh going through mom down here
we go we're in the nuts
run enough romneyís hold on go alright
there's in the capital it's all right
there okay or one two three go quick go
right Oh God I don't know if you nope
get [ __ ] sorry I'm awful there's so many
[ __ ] dudes there so we do the parkour
thing or like yeah well I think we
should go down the alley hey cars up you
shoot those two cars and it's kind of
clear ok Ryeon maybe alright let's try
that let's try it out clear this
alleyway as best as we can I get on my
way get on the way just shoot it won't
kill us I don't think it's just [ __ ]
walk down any stupid [ __ ] that's what
I'm saying
yes are you grabbing doing this [ __ ]
get the car to go who wants to do the
bag I can use some we're gonna back some
to the back right now oh god Chuck I
don't have a I got a grenade it's gonna
have to do I got it yeah we're good this
is cool ok nice work this is the best
we've done above you to the right I got
him on the steps I don't think it's
finished though ok
he's got shotguns don't get close [ __ ] -
I'm getting shot sit back just right go
fix it everybody run run run run right
there has it got there ahead Go Go Go Go
Go Go oh all right
the stress is real exercise torque oh we
killed so many police why did we put her
get away the vehicles closer all right
Mike remember the left stick is Boost
maybe use it sparingly so you have to
ease off the gas in order to recharge it
yeah it's kurz that's the kinetic energy
reduction
system recovery recovery systems are all
right let's do it
all right get the [ __ ] out of here best
of luck folks oh man these flags are so
fat either [ __ ] [ __ ] this I'm just
hitting them [ __ ] slopes what I boys
are linked up boosting both whoo I this
intense it's so cool really like to ride
first reasons gone girl first pair don't
get you can't watch those poles on the
side of the road yeah okay well messed
up cops up ahead
yeah remember guys you got no more debts
oh [ __ ] I'm in the tunnel and - oh no
and I got shot by some Popo whoo that's
fine I like to do that again
actually that's okay yeah that was
really fun although I'm crazy mall
deities on it mmm-hmm that's the thing
it turns into a race and then it's like
so many it wasn't worth winning the sand
of the KERS boost sounds like the same
sound as dying so every time you guys
use it I feel felt somebody shot and the
colors yeah that's totally fair cops are
really effective at getting me off the
bike oh I always did damn
damn son I think the highway for me
actually was the best because you have a
lot of room to avoid people like I like
stuff so the thing is is that we're
supposed to go to the canyon right yeah
you take the highway into doing this
yeah it's bruising it's verging to the
right you can take it for a period of
time if you like but you're gonna have
to make a left
yeah at some point
now let's move joke oh my gosh tickets
have boys and girls don't die that's top
order of the motto here yeah there's Oh
tight please won't we see that thread
that needle
I said raisi ballsy stupid but balls
stupid from you stupid what you ballsy
oh my god there's so many I like my
father's like [ __ ] give up can't find
my [ __ ] bike oh that's dude that's
the worst oh where you give knocks
Austin has your bike goes flying and it
doesn't show you where it is there's no
like icon this would be so good if we
get to the end and it's like we can
plate it and do it like 5 grand
yeah actually pretty funny it should be
you and robbing armored car
alright come to you Danny got it go so
there's a problem with this armored car
it's like super slow oh they are also
firing at it I was like you firing out
yeah they've like hey you guys in on the
bikes
alright good sorry about your funds no
sir sorry about your friends good they
see the farmer outside go Drago good God
darn it I just rebelled ah yes yesterday
there goes my weekend darn kids there
police yes
ok your bank heist marry you I don't
know I am right on your butt Andy's dick
all right
how much Park yeah feel like maybe I
should be using the gun but okay we
don't think of better than moments ago I
just automatically was more important
why are you oh I know I kind of went up
why don't we road to go ahead gosh did
you get that oh my god hey Rob gonna get
a stretcher
I'm not gonna block I'm gonna block them
okay do you run forward
I'm here to pick you up
okay go Eddie shall we wait keep calling
Mary get on okay oh man if this all this
is so cooling the shot oh my god Wow
three minutes we're there
we're at it okay off the cliff again
parachuting oh man we actually could
have made this talk about 15 seconds
away ouch so close so close was that
are we supposed to been parachute yeah
sorry that's not funny wasn't might not
hit it if I had another yeah verified
function whoa should we just do it no no
no no no leap of faith no all wait till
we get here we all here it says jump off
the cliff from begin parachuting but
hold on get to the edge of the cliff and
then it just says get in the dinghy
well the dinghies down there yeah but
can we get there without [ __ ] Yolo no
ah [ __ ] hey didn't I come up you know
you guys jump far out I tried I did I
like oh I think I might start here
around we might start here we might I'll
be awesome okay we start here it is it's
right here yeah it is it's not going
back good job no first you go we gotta
stop the clock still ticking I'm doing
it Eddie Lee oh my god oh oh you know
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
drive off in the motorcycle okay with
speed everyone's on the path which we
were [ __ ] good we don't really [ __ ] up
here really one more copy I regret is
that one copy
hey maybe just kill he will shoot you
are you all right let me maybe doing
here he's hanging out I had a hunch he
was over here like [ __ ] my beavers
I'm just terrifying under drive possible
time he's gonna shock will be like
[ __ ] he has a real band that's young
lucky shot okay cuz he get promoted oh
my god
oh yes it doesn't work this time I'll
[ __ ] don't say that it isn't work Oh
space it out so one person first or just
go we're gonna go this I'm just gonna do
it I'm gonna go right now go okay you're
[ __ ] go I'm gonna go lost and scared
okay it's easy
yeah it's good no problems good oh yeah
oh all right
let's for do not die down try to keep
some glide and distance don't lose any
altitude don't lose altitude I wouldn't
lose that much altitude cuz I don't know
how far away this thing is Lachlan this
is so stressful yeah where is this dingy
it's close okay suppose and I thought
it's right in this river right yeah okay
see it I see it already
should we dunk in the river no no no
follow me on the from the first guy
follow me it's easy so it was clear the
roads going dude all right down okay
come down along with that I'm done oh my
god I love you guys oh my god
been through a lot together we've been
to oh I'm not in I think I got pushed
[ __ ]
everyone here let's go I'm not funny oh
all right sit all right take a Pew why
won't you say doesn't suit you yeah is
it the crack again Jesus can I can't all
right you guys look alive
I have a feeling we're going to be
cheating I'm gonna pick up oh my gosh
it's gotta be a checkpoint at least I
think I count the final thing got it no
I think that might be it
yeah yeah we pull it up you did it I
know much but yeah and yeah here okay
you better take off and take care okay
bye bye bye Lester yeah we did that
business well okay marry primary flat
even wrong way to go surprise
you're my favorite fourth place - ah
nice work now let's never speak of that
again oh yeah oh that's beautiful
yeah no mail so that we all wore our
best to this yeah well you know yeah we
should weren't wearing clothes